hey guys my name is just it is the
festive December and here's some gaming
new things for you monday first up
resident evil 7 s latest demo update
midnight is coming to scare the pants
off pc and xbox one players very soon
the update which is already available on
ps4 with an optional vr mode will arrive
on xbox one on december nine and pc on
december 19 midnight updates resident
evils beginning our demo and capcom said
it allows players to further explore
quote what lies beyond the mold covered
or where terrifying growling noises
emanate from having played the land and
demo in vr for resident evil 7 I can
tell you I had absolutely no interest in
exploring what lies beyond the vault
covered door and this demo will require
a player fast earlier than me maybe you
damn resident evil 7 is that on January
24 of next year Bungie has revealed more
details about what to expect from
Destiny's upcoming event the dawning the
dorling serves as both a holiday update
and this year's iteration of Sparrow
racing league the dawning holiday is
rooted in destiny law and the update is
also bringing a new scoring system for
strikes Sparrow racing will operate
similarly to last year with two new
tracks and the opportunity to infuse
gear so it's more likely to be useful to
long term going forward Sparrow racing
will be added as an option for private
matches after the conclusion of the
dawning event a record book which tracks
all the players account-wide activities
will also be available to anyone who
owns rise of iron which will provide you
with objectives as you race the dawning
record book also features strike scoring
which will put you on a path way to
earning new exotic heavy machineguns
zabala will also have quests where you
can earn accolades for things like kill
streaks of flawless runs and speed runs
three strikes the shadow thief nexus and
will of crota are getting a new hard
modifier that introduces double slices
into pre-existing missions the dawning
begins on December 13 and runs until
you're finally Mass Effect Andromeda
creative director Mac Walters has shed
extra info on the upcoming sci-fi RPG
Walters previously said on Twitter that
Bioware would be polishing the game
until quote they take it from our cold
dead hands he reiterated to gamespot
that Bioware was inspired by destiny for
Andromeda's combat mechanics
particularly concerning the fluid
movement typed combat mechanics and
camera controls he added that the studio
is confident that the game will make its
spring 2017 release date walters
explained that Andromeda story is more
useful and adventurous and the game has
been purposefully designed with
verticality in mind when it comes to
environments head to gamespot for our
reviews on the oculus touch and the Last
Guardian and I'll see you again tomorrow